hi carolina welcome to serverless
expeditions thank you martin
you are a cloud run product manager and
i hear you've worked on a way to make
cloud run even more useful
that's right
we've released cloud run jobs which
makes it easier to use cloudran for
unattended batch jobs like database
migrations report generation and so on
can't wait to hear more about it
[Music]
developers like cloudrun because it lets
you run containers in a serverless way
containers are good because they make it
easy to package up your application and
the libraries it needs and serverless is
good because it means your cloud
provider worries about scaling up and
down so you don't have to right right
so far you've been able to trigger cloud
run executions on http calls or events
like a file being added to cloud storage
but there are some workloads that aren't
well suited for that what kind of
workloads well you might have a database
migration or cleanup work
an export or import process reports to
generate and so on these jobs need to
run unattended without an http request
from a user also they should run to
completion oh right
back in my sysadmin days i had many
things that weren't web servers like
maintenance scripts exactly
these jobs often take longer than it
takes to process an http request or an
event typically minutes instead of
seconds
right i remember setting up a virtual
machine to run some of those scripts
many organizations do that but it's
inefficient you have to manage and
configure the virtual machine
and you have to remember to take it down
once your job finishes or pay for it 24
7.
also it can't easily scale up to run
really large jobs
yeah i only use the virtual machine for
scripts like that because there was no
serverless way of doing it back then
well now there is it's called
cloudrendjobs
it's still serverless it's still running
containers but it works better for
unattended workloads that aren't
triggered by http calls that sounds good
but i suspect it's still not completely
clear to everyone how it works
we are developers and we'd like to see
code and a demo
well let's hope the demo goes are with
me imagine a company receives invoices
from its vendors as pdf files
here are a few examples of what they
might look like
every night they want to extract the
vendor names and totals from those pdfs
so their finance team can review and
approve them the next day got it i've
built nightly jobs like that before
right now here's the code
this part reads the invoice files from
google cloud storage
this part calls the document ai api to
extract vendor names and totals from
each invoice
this part writes the invoice data to
firestore
and finally this part moves the
processed invoices to another folder so
they won't get picked up next time the
job runs
and once the job runs how will we see
the parsed invoice data we also have
this simple web page that reads the
parsed invoice data from firestore and
displays it to the user
got it uh would we deploy the invoice
parsing job like a regular cloud run
service it's similar you first build
your container with google cloud build
and then create your job with gcloud run
jobs create
let me create it right now
okay
this code you showed me does not listen
to http calls so how do we get it to run
well you can run it from the google
cloud console or the command line it's
similar to running a shell script on
your computer but it runs in the cloud
and has access to all your google cloud
resources
let me do that now
there it goes
looks like something ran
can we see the output of the job let's
have a look
i'll go to the simple webpage that
displays the parse details from the
invoices
looks like it captured the invoice data
nice uh but carolina what if i want to
run a nightly job when i'm not at my
keyboard anything that can call the
cloud run admin api can start the job
including cloud scheduler
let's use cloud scheduler to make our
job run every night
i go to cloud scheduler
create a new job
give it a name and a region to run in
set a schedule for it to run using cron
tab notation
and a time zone
click continue
target type http
enter the cloud run admin api endpoint
to run your job
you can find that in the
documentation and keep http method as
post
now we have to give cloud scheduler
permissions to start the job i click
here to pick oauth token
and then i select which service account
scheduler should use to start the job
i know this one has sufficient
permission
you need a service account that has the
cloud run invoker permission on the job
then i click create
now the job will be run nightly you
won't have to be at your keyboard at
midnight martin
that that's a relief uh
the the code you showed me processed one
invoice at a time in series
if we have a thousand invoices that
would take a long time uh can we speed
it up somehow yes you can tell cloudrun
jobs to start several parallel tasks
let's say you have a thousand invoices
and you start 10 parallel tasks
your code can detect what number task it
is for example 4 out of 10
then your code can process its part of
the total work
for task number four that would be
invoices 301 to 400. sounds very useful
for large jobs
like big old data migration jobs that
need to process millions of records
um do you have a code example for that
let's save that for another video martin
also it's all in the documentation
uh the link is in the description
very good thanks for showing us uh
and thank you everyone for watching if
you have questions for carolina or me
let us know in the comments also let us
know if there are other server-less
topics you'd like to hear about
until next time
[Music]
you